let's get into the mailbag boy was it a
special treat to get back from my week
off and hear from so many people Furious
that I ever take time off and also from
people who were glad I was gone now to
the people who were glad I was gone you
know you don't have to watch my content
when I'm not on vacation you can just
not watch it and that's totally allowed
and acceptable but let's get to some
marginally more substantive stuff
starting as we sometimes do with an
adversarial comment I don't run away
from these Stephen wrote in and said
you're awoke Lefty but your was the
wrong your almost a requirement at this
point you're awoke Lefty joke should be
banned from social media for pushing the
lies of the democratic party
you're paid by them the wrong you're
again
and as we sometimes do
we respond simply with y o u apostrophe
r-e I maintain my challenge I have been
accused of being paid for by the
Democratic party of globalish uh I've
been accused of being paid for by the
Democratic party George Soros Bill Gates
big Pharma whatever
for over a decade and I still am waiting
for anyone to present some evidence of
that
and uh it's an open invitation info info
davidpackman.com if you have that
evidence please send it to me Jason
wrote in about the forthcoming
children's book we are working on Jason
says David the word critical should
appear nowhere in your children's book
if you use that word your book will be
banned in many places I suggest using
media literacy rather than critical
thinking in these discussions at least
where the audience is likely to be media
illiterate I do agree
that such
value-neutral terms as critical thinking
and actually media literacy as well
have become weaponized by the right who
say uh oh media literacy that's liberal
indoctrination it is true that the more
media literate people are the less
likely they are are to fall for these
right-wing tropes and ideas that is
absolutely true but that's because
they're learning to think for themselves
not because they are being indoctrinated
uh and Jason is probably right more info
on the forthcoming book very very soon
Lizzie wrote in I asked should I cover
these bogus house coveted hearings that
Republicans are planning to have
Lizzy Rhoden and said no please don't
cover the hearings live it totally
legitimizes them and there's so many
people who come to your page also
judging by some of the emails and
voicemails people seem to hate when you
talk or comment over proceedings anyway
I know can you imagine if what my show
was is I take the C-SPAN feed of a
hearing
and I sit there like a piece of wood or
clay or metal
um for the three hours and don't say a
word like no nobody's coming here for
that go to C-SPAN if that's what you
want Lizzy I appreciate you pointing out
the absurdity of that
uh who else wrote in Jeremy wrote in
about Trump anti-vaxxers and 2024.
Jeremy says from Chicago hey David love
your show I have thoughts on Trump and
anti-vaxxers I believe Trump won't win
the 2024 primaries if he is still in
support of the covet vaccine more and
more of his Ardent supporters hate the
vaccine and the vaccinated most recently
silk from diamond and silk Trump knows
his base hates the vaccine and he needs
to change his tune in order for him to
have a chance at winning the 2024
presidency let me know your thoughts
yeah I mean listen Jeremy you're not
wrong that it's a little hard the mental
gymnastics required for
praise me for the great job I did
developing the vaccine
which
might be really bad for you and you
should have the freedom not to take and
it should never be mandated and it's a
beautiful lovely Freedom thing for
people not to get vaccinated
that I got all three doses of speaking
As Trump now or however many doses he's
up to
but praise me for it but don't get it it
is a really difficult place to be in and
the reason it's particularly difficult
for Trump is he doesn't have many
accomplishments to speak of from his
first term I mean he he claims
accomplishments they're mostly lies and
so he needs stuff to to brag about
the vaccine stuff is not seen as an
accomplishment by many of his followers
I don't know what he's going to do how
he will position that in 24. uh but
it'll be interesting to see Alex wrote
in about the double standards of the
right and says hey David wanted to point
out Republicans were accusing Obama of
lying about his childhood where he was
born Etc despite no evidence of this
meanwhile they are A-Okay with Santos
who has been caught in multiple lives of
a somewhat similar nature their right
has so many double standards ironically
they have absolutely no standards for
who they actually elect with all due
respect Alex Alex you said it so
perfectly
I couldn't possibly add anything to it
you are completely correct
Stephen wrote in about Michael Cohen's
show Maya culpa saying I wanted to
mention to you Michael Cohen has
repeated numerous times in his show that
you go to different Trump rallies and
events interviewing people to show the
irony of their positions I know you've
highlighted some of these interviews in
the past but I'm fairly certain you're
just quoting or replaying these from
other sources that aren't produced by
your show directly I thought you might
want to correct them unless I'm mistaken
yeah it has been brought to my attention
multiple times that Michael Cohen who's
a friend of the show thinks I go to
Trump rallies it is true that I don't go
to the Trump rallies
but we do have our correspondence and in
particular Luke Beasley who does go to
the event so we are generating original
content at those rallies but it is true
that I'm not the guy who goes to them if
I have the opportunity to correct uh
Michael I will Brian wrote in about
socialism socialism Brian says hello
David I want to ask a question about the
term socialism as Paul Krugman once
suggested in regards to Bernie using the
term socialism gives any opposition The
Leverage to compare one to Stalin I've
heard you stayed on your show that there
are no real socialists in government and
I tend to agree
when I listen to your views on
government economy health care I think
you're pretty reasonable however do you
agree that left-wing politicians and
pundits and influencers should distance
themselves from the term I don't expect
you to be responsible for others but I
think it's fair criticism to point out
that people like Kyle kolinsky and
vausch turn people off of actual issues
with their abstract understandings and
glorification of socialism okay I don't
know I can't speak to Kyle and vouch Ian
Bosh however you know him
here is should people distance
themselves from the term socialism
if you are really a socialist
then you should embrace the term because
that's really what you are to the extent
that the Democratic Party
really doesn't have socialists in it
uh in positions of power I don't think
anybody who isn't actually a socialist
should embrace the term because it's
both inaccurate and not advantageous now
I know that there's polling that says
well young people are less negative
about socialism than ever before
young people specifically and less
negative doesn't to me signal that it's
a winner
to say we are socialists when we are not
my general view is
in particular if you're not really a
socialist don't embrace the term and
this I think has been one of my biggest
criticisms of the way Bernie ran his
campaigns
uh
let's call ourselves what we are
I am a Social Democrat that's a
regulated form of capitalism and I will
repeat it as many times as I need to
repeat it in order to get that across we
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today please sign up at joinpakman.com
we do directly depend on the support of
people who get memberships at
joinpakman.com I would love for you to
be one of those people we will see you
on the bonus show and then back here
next week